immer häufiger stoßen wir auf solche
schlagzeilen sie titeln unter menschen
mit ausländischen wurzeln breitet sich
das virus besonders schnell aus wir
wollen wissen ist das stimmungsmache
oder stimmen diese vorwürfe
wir beginnen mit unseren recherchen da
wo die infektions treiber wohnen sollen
etwa im berliner stadtteil neukölln und
wir möchten den arzt treffen der das
tabu thema angestoßen hat
aber passt auf ich seit ich würde sagen
ich recherchiere in berlin
und du du gehst in die kliniken chance
was da wirklich los ist
berlin neukölln ein stadtbezirk mit rund
330 1000 einwohnern knapp die hälfte hat
einen migrationshintergrund mehr als ein
drittel lebt unter der armutsgrenze
zum zeitpunkt unseres drews liegt die
inzidenz bei 150 in gesamtberlin 218 in
neukölln die bezirksverwaltung versucht
gegenzusteuern
ein multikulturelles aufklärungs team
informiert in zwölf sprachen damit jeder
hier die korona maßnahmen verstehen kann
ich arbeite für das gesundheitsamt
wenn sie fragen haben können sie sich an
mich wenden
die behörde befürchtet islamische
feiertage können wie christliche zu
super special events werden bei dem
ramadan sehr viele familien sich treffen
mit sehr viel verwandtschaft und dass
das schon erfahrung des gesundheits
anderen grund zur sorge weil tendenziell
an die gefahr besteht dass er da das
sich privat dann was wir was dann wieder
weiter verbreiten kann unsere und
wiederum kontrolliert verwalten kann
ra beständige migranten fühlen sich oft
von deutschen medien stigmatisiert
doch uns heißt eine libanesische
großfamilie willkommen
ihr engster kreis besteht aus etwa 20
personen aus drei generationen wegen
ihrer herkunft sind sie nicht nur mit
alten vorurteilen sondern nun auch mit
neuen vorwürfen konfrontiert
eine zusätzliche belastung inmitten der
pandemie dass die clans oder oder
irgendwelche machenschaften oder
arabischen groß hochzeiten oder
beerdigungen et cetera die
suzuki wenz werden und die cds
hochtreiben das ist englisch empirisch
fundiert nicht belegt und von daher
empfinde ich das als als als
populistisch und und seines klient wenn
somit arabischen clans umgegangen wird
die familienmitglieder sind im
einzelhandel in der sicherheitsbranche
oder in vereinen tätig der kontakt zu
anderen ist dort unvermeidbar einen teil
ihrer freizeit verbringen sie in der
moschee wie für kirchen gelten auch für
die islamischen gotteshäuser strenge
auflagen
also die moscheen haben sogar ihre
typische markiert abstands markierungen
eingehalten
die leute sind allem diesen angehalten
mit ihrem eigenen privaten gebetsteppich
zu kommen
sie dürfen die gebetsnische der moschee
nicht vollziehen sondern müssten müssen
das schon von zu hause machen
sie müssen sich in listen eintragen es
gibt auch moscheegemeinden diese art
ausweis erstellt haben für die für die
besucher besonders jetzt im ramadan
vermissen sie das allabendliche
fastenbrechen in großer runde
das gemeindeleben fehlt wirklich totalen
das merke ich denke das spüren auch
meine schwester im glauben dass es
wirklich fehlt weil die kinder auch
einfach die ganzen anderen kinder sehen
essen gemeinsam essen
das fehlt wirklich spiritualität im
ramadan geht quasi offen und
normalerweise treffen sich alle acht
geschwister mit ihren partnern und
kindern bei den eltern dieses jahr
wechseln sie sich ab mit ihren besuchen
um das ansteckungsrisiko kleiner zu
halten weil wir das hautnah erlebt haben
ich mein ehemann meine eigene fleisch
und blut der vater einer serbischen
freundin ist gestorben daran also das
sind sehr nahe leute die im erkrankt
sind hat dass man unter dem boden unter
den füßen gerissen
als ich gehört habe dass meine tochter
krank ist war das schwierigste für mich
dass ich sie nicht besuchen konnte es
war so schlimm dass sie schlafmittel
nehmen musste ich war so in sorge weil
ich sie nicht sehen konnte
dem bischof die familie versichert ihr
bestes zu tun um sich und andere zu
schützen
aber wie ist die lage auf den
intensivstationen liegen dort wirklich
mehr migranten die lungenabteilung der
bethanien klinik in moers ihr leiter dr
thomas voß h brachte anfang 2021 den
stein ins rollen in einer privaten runde
mit ärger vieler teilte er seine
beobachtung dass die mehrheit seiner
patienten migranten seien seine brisante
botschaft kam durch ein leck an die
öffentlichkeit und bald darauf in die
oft reißerischen schlagzeilen
ich habe mich am anfang unglaublich um
wohl damit gefühlt und war ganz und gar
verunsichert dass man da missverstanden
wird dass man in dieser rassismus ecke
kommt für mich und für uns im haus ging
es immer nur um die frage ob wir
überhaupt eine adäquate fürsorge diesen
menschen zuteil kommen lassen ob wir
nicht etwas außer acht lassen eben weil
wir sehen nicht erreichen
er zeigt uns die korona station auch in
diesen tagen liegen hier patienten die
kaum deutsch können nicht die
migrationsgeschichte sei das problem
sondern die fehlenden sprachkenntnisse
so dr fonds h nur wenn man daten über
die familiäre und sprachliche herkunft
besonders gefährdete gruppen habe könne
man sie schützen
alle wären immer ab und sagen wir haben
keine zahlen
und ich sag immer ja dann sorgt doch
bitte dafür dass du jetzt mal welche
kriegen denn ich habe es doch jetzt
schon vor monaten gesagt dass wir jetzt
mal gucken müssen
dazu müsste man jetzt einen sag mal ganz
einfach so was wie ein fragebogen
entwickeln
das ist aber meiner ansicht nach schnell
gemacht das können spezialisten die
wissen welche fragen brauchen wir und
das müssen wir dann einfach an alle
intensivstationen in alle krankenhäuser
verschicken rückmeldung zum beispiel an
das lka oder bundesministerium für
gesundheit und dann hätten wir diese
informationen schon längst und könnten
auch sehr gezielt handeln
warum man das nicht macht wird er damit
begründet dass man sagt datenschutz
persönlichkeitsrechte grundrecht ja ok
haben sie den eindruck dass ihre
patienten ein problem damit händler gar
nicht gar nicht ein nicht aber da hätten
die meisten menschen tag keine probleme
und das ist auch meine erfahrung wenn
man den menschen erklärt um was es geht
dann sagen sie nein hier machen
wir wollen genau wissen welche zahlen
liegen vor
welche nicht
zuständig für die datenerfassung die
gesundheitsministerien der bundesländer
wir fragen nach bei allen die antworten
sind ernüchternd
keines der 16 bundesländer erhebt daten
über die ethnischen wurzeln der kurve 19
patienten nur zwei dokumentieren die
sozialen und wirtschaftlichen
verhältnisse der infizierten
gleichzeitig suchen wir nach studien die
einen zusammenhang zwischen
migrationsgeschichte und
infektionsrisiko erforscht haben was wir
finden ist unbefriedigend kann nicht
sein wir sind jetzt im zweiten jahr der
pandemie und es gibt keine daten
eigentlich überall ist die situation so
dass sich jeden tag tausende menschen
infizieren und wir wissen nicht wer wo
unter welchen umständen
informationserfassung ist unter anderem
die aufgabe der landes gesundheitsämter
die patientendaten bekommen sie von den
behandelnden medizinern
wir möchten von doktor teichert
vorsitzende des bundesverbandes der
ärztinnen im öffentlichen dienst wissen
warum die soziologischen hintergründe
nicht erfragt werden
[Musik]
gesundheitsberichterstattung
datenerfassung ist schon seit jahren
machen wir das ja aber nicht in dem
ausmaß wie wir es hätten machen können
ich glaube aber auch nicht dass wenn wir
die daten gehabt hätten dass wir nicht
von japan überrascht gewesen wären weil
mit der situation hat er wirklich so
keiner gerechnet
ein jahrzehntelanges versäumnis dass man
kurzfristig nicht nachholen kann
also ich glaube dass die ärzte insgesamt
mehr daten erfassen das geht auf gar
keinen fall
und weil ich weiß nicht wie das in der
arztpraxis oder auch im krankenhaus
gehen soll weil dir auf behandlung
ausgerichtet sind
unser gesundheitswesen wird wegen seiner
bürokratie oft kritisiert aber hier wäre
es nötig gewesen daten zu erheben um
nicht im blindflug durch die pandemie zu
steuern
andere länder wie zum beispiel england
und die usa zeigen dass dies möglich ist
so haben amerikanische studien gezeigt
dass schwarze und latinos bis zu
dreieinhalb mal häufiger an corona
erkranken als andere
es sterben doppelt so viele schwarze und
dreimal so viele latinos an dem virus
als weiße amerikaner die sind auch
schlechter aufgeklärt und lassen sich
seltener impfen weil sie der regierung
nicht vertrauen
die internationalen studien machen
deutlich arbeitslosigkeit armut
schlechte wohnverhältnisse und
sprachdefizite sind entscheidende
risikofaktoren
wir wollen von den landes
gesundheitsministerien wissen warum
diese informationen in deutschland nicht
erfasst werden
in ihren antwortschreiben wird vor allem
auf datenschutzgesetze verwiesen
[Musik]
aber stimmt es dass der datenschutz das
befragen von patienten zu ihren
lebensverhältnissen verbietet dazu
befragen wir den datenschutz
beauftragten der bundesregierung
professor ulrich kelber er lebe jetzt
seit vielen monaten das datenschutz auf
das bequeme ausrede verwendet wird ich
kenne aus den gesprächen mit meinen
zuständigen kollegin kollegen aus den
ländern zum beispiel keinen einzigen
fall eines gesundheitsamtes dass
bestimmte zusätzliche daten nach oben
wollte und dann dafür keine grünes licht
bekommen er verweist auf die
grundsätzlichen probleme in der
datenverarbeitung und nutzung in der tat
haben wir mehr daten zur verfügung als
verarbeitet werden wir haben einen
unglaublichen rückstand in der
digitalisierung und wir erleben hat
tatsächlich oft das ist eine bequeme
ausrede oder auch ein sündenbock ist in
datenschutz heranzuziehen
das bundesgesundheitsministerium könnte
den anstoß für die erfassung von
sozialen wirtschaftlichen und
technischen daten geben warum dies nicht
geschieht wollen wir den zuständigen
minister fragen doch jens spahn lehnt
ein interview ab aus zeitgründen sein
pressesprecher verweist auf statements
die sparen bereits zu dem thema gab zb
auf die frage eines journalisten ob es
konkrete zahlen zum anteil der migranten
an corona patienten geben was wir nicht
können weil sie woran wollen sie denn
erkennen ob jemand einen
migrationshintergrund hat also dass man
das irgendwie nachnamen erkennt ist
schon lange nicht mehr so sieht also wie
wollen sie auf einer intensivstation
diese statistik führen die manche
einfordern die ist aus meiner sicht wenn
man sie überhaupt führen wollte da kann
man schon drüber streiten so gar nicht
so leicht zu führen weil was soll was
soll das kriterium für diese frage sein
keine erklärung die überzeugt denn in
anderen ländern ist eine breitere
datenerfassung möglich wie wir erfahren
haben
zurück in berlin neukölln wir sind mit
dem bezirksbürgermeister martin hikel
verabredet er weiß warum die menschen
hier ist im kampf gegen das virus
schwerer haben sicherheit daran liegt
dass für eine sehr hohe einwohnerdichte
haben dass wir in neukölln viele
menschen haben die nicht mit einem
laptop von zu hause aus arbeiten können
sondern viele müssen er trotzdem zur
arbeit müssen wenn du da auch die
baustelle in den supermarkt und hinter
die kasse und dann gibt es keinen home
office einer studie zufolge liegt der
anteil von migranten im systemrelevanten
niedriglohnsektor bei rund 36 prozent
der anteil von nicht migranten bei 20
prozent
kuriere fahrer pflegekräfte die
zwangsläufig viele kontakte haben
eine von ihnen ist die ehemalige
altenpflegerin hier ehepaar yeti wir
besuchen sie in ihrer wohnung in
oberschöneweide die mazedonierin hat
sich bereits im april 2020 bei der
arbeit mit dem virus infiziert
ich vermisse mein leben ich vermisse
arbeiten zu gehen aber die in mir drin
ich vermisse nur dass ich meine
gesundheit wieder habe ich möchte die
sein die ich vor einem jahr war die
reality leidet immer noch an staaten
lankowitz symptomen unter anderem an
schweren atemproblemen und tiefe
erschöpfung
die ffb mussten licht damals werden
diese einfachen muskeln das heißt da kam
luft rein verlogen von unten auf alle
seiten und ich war so nah an dem gesicht
später stellte sich heraus ihr
schützling hatte corona ich war die
ganze zeit bei ihr ist die app verlor
nicht nur ihre gesundheit
sie kann ihren job nicht weiter ausüben
steht finanziell am abgrund wie es
weitergehen soll
sie weiß es nicht ich habe immer
versucht zu erarbeiten um immer ein
vorbild für meine kinder zu sein immer
und nicht vom jobcenter zu leben und auf
einmal zu sagen das war's du hast die
wahl entweder auf rente oder du gehst
jetzt zum jobcenter und ich weiß nicht
was sie machen kann
zum ersten mal in meinem ganzen leben
fühle ich mich hilflos
belastbare daten gibt es nicht aber
beobachtungen überdurchschnittlich viele
migranten leben in prekären
verhältnissen und damit ist ihr anteil
an corona erkrankten ebenfalls höher
denn armut und krankheit begünstigen
sich dazu gibt es studien für martin
hikel ist es inakzeptabel dass migranten
dafür als infektionsträger stigmatisiert
werden
sehr ärgerlich weil es lenkt eigentlich
vom eigentlichen problemen ab nämlich
dass die gefahr infiziert zu werden
massgeblich davon abhängig ist nicht
coleman mitbringt und dass der
gesundheitliche zustand von menschen
leider auch davon abhängt welche welchen
sozialen background sie haben und das
ist der eigentliche skandal das wird
natürlich überdeckt von verkürzten
darstellungen migranten seien wisse
nichts davon betroffen er bedauert es
dass die regierungen puncto chor ohne
aufklärung migranten wenig im blick
hatte ich wünsche mir sehr dass die
informationen die seitens der
bundesregierung und seitens des landes
unterländer auch veröffentlicht werden
selbstverständlich auch in anderen
sprachen veröffentlicht werden besseres
kommunikationsmanagement montieren
pragmatisch kommunikationsmanagement das
würde uns hier vor ort wirklich helfen
sehr helfen
martin hikel hat die initiative
ergriffen und ein aufklärungs team auf
die straße geschickt seine aufgabe es
soll die neue kölner die wenig oder gar
kein deutsch sprechen in ihren
muttersprachen über corona informieren
das ist ein projekt vom rathaus neukölln
um den migranten zu ermöglichen die
korona maßnahmen zu verstehen und
missverständnisse gibt es hier viele
kinder nicht in die schule weil es
einfach angst haben sie ist dem kind
schaden einfach sage dass der regel
viele migranten beziehen informationen
zu corona aus ihren herkunftsländern
diese menschen haben diese fahrzeuge wie
kommen diese information von der heimat
und da sind die korona bilder nie so
strikt wie hier einige bilder wurden die
feiern wie hochzeiten mit ca zwar ist
keine beziehung mit 200 darunter person
da die sitze nebeneinander keine maske
gar nichts
wieso tut mir da ich nicht so schlimm
ist nur eine normale erkältung die
offiziellen informationen kommentieren
nicht bei allen an dafür verbreiten sich
verschwörungstheorien
viele kriegen ihre informationen von
facebook oder von esther rahm oder von
von youtube und das ist eine hülle und
fülle von falschinformationen eine der
fragen die wir die bei uns in letzter
zeit wieder verstärkt auf doch ist es ob
der ob es stimmt dass er sich in den
masken würmern befinden und ob es stimmt
dass astrazeneca und fruchtbar macht
oder jetzt auch bei uns
das aufklärungs team tut sein bestes im
kampf gegen das virus aber es braucht
mehr um risikogruppen wie zum beispiel
menschen mit migrationshintergrund zu
schützen was helfen könnte weiß
bezirksbürgermeister martin hikel
schließen wir einfach zur bewältigung
zur pandemie ist das dürfen wir haben
die men und women power gibt es den
impfstoff also für mich hat gerade den
bezirken neukölln wo in die inzidenz
doch mal schnell nach oben ist als in
anderen quartieren so eine hohe
impfquoten eine ganz hohe relevanz und
darum auch die aufklärung über selten
ganz wichtig damit sie möglichst viele
leute sagen ich kann es gar nicht warten
abend zuerst hin zu halten und den jahre
rein zu bekommen ist nicht die
motivation
wie heikel das thema der priorisierten
impfung in sozialen brennpunkten ist
wird deutlich wenn sich der
gesundheitsminister dazu äußert die
frage der impf priorisierung und der
risiken für soziale ungleichgewichte das
ist aber nicht per sehen thema der
priorisierung sondern eher eine frage
der wirklich zielgruppen und sozialen
gruppen spezifischen ansprache im
gerechtigkeit nur eines von vielen
minenfeldern bei der pandemie bekämpfung
fakt ist das virus trifft menschen in
prekären lebensverhältnissen härter als
den rest der gesellschaft
darunter sind viele migranten denen
sprachkenntnisse und der zugang zu
informationen fehlen die weniger hilfe
erhalten
das thema enttabuisieren und daten
erheben das wären erste schritte um sie
besser zu schützen
[Musik]